in the killing of a sacred deer Colin
Farrell plays a heart surgeon named
Stephen Murphy whose fondness for the
bottle contributed to the death of a
patient Stephen refuses to admit any
wrongdoing and that's just not going to
sit with the patient's son an unusual
teen by the name of Martin Lang your son
told me that you've got lots of hair
under your arms three times more than I
do there's something off about Martin
and that's before he Reveals His Godlike
power to enact revenge on Stephen's
entire family as part of his revenge
scheme Martin tells Stephen all his
family members are going to die of a
mysterious illness and after they start
bleeding from their eyes they'll die the
only way Stephen can stop this plague is
by killing a member of his family the
movie gets even darker when the family
turns on each other arguing why they
shouldn't be the one to die the
desperation the Betrayal the blood it's
also cruel and it culminates in one of
the most disturbing climaxes ever filmed
horrific in ways that no slasher film
could ever achieve the killing of a
sacred deer is a powerful film that you
won't watch more than once